نحن الان نقف في مقبره الشهداء هذه
المقبره التي دفن فيها الشهداء حديثا بعد
القصف الاسرائيلي المتواصل وارتفاع عدد
الشهداء الكبير في داخل مدينه غزه هذه
ذخائر قوات الاحتلال الفارغه التي استخدمت
داخل مدينه غزه هذه قذائف صاروخيه
استخدمتها قوات الاحتلال داخل مدينه غزه
وتركت اثار هذه القذائف في هذا المكان بعد
ان جرفت قوات الاحتلال المقبره وتركت
جثامين الشهداء خارج المقبره بالاضافه
انها داست الجثامين باليات قوات الاحتلال
الان كثير من هذه الجثث هي خارج
القبور قوات الاحتلال عملت على استخراج
هذه الجثث والتنكيل بها خارج المقبره نرى
هناك بشكل اوضح في هذه المكان في هذا
المكان بقايا جثث الشهداء الذين دفنوا
داخل هذه المقبره الان قوات
الاحتلال استخرجت هذه الجثث من داخل
القبور ووفق المواطنين انها عملت على اخذ
بعض الجثث من داخل المقبره وبقيت هذه
الاثار هي داخل هذه المقبره الكثير من
الجثث في هذا المكان لو نرى بشكل موضح على
طول الممر ايش ايش ايش اللي صار اللي صار
انه هذا عدو مجرم يعني حتى الاموات خرجوه
من المقابر يعني هذا لا شرع ولا دين ولا
اي اسلام ولا اي ديانات تقبل هذا العدو
المجرم ان يعمل فهؤلاء
الاموات ايش سوي الاموات هذول هذه بريه
احنا بحترم كل الديانات لكن هذا عدو لم
يحترم شيئا والله انا اولادي الاثنين
واخويا وابن اخويا دفنتم ه ما انت شايف
ايش اج عاملين تخريب وانتقام حتى الاموات
ما سلمت منهم بقايا اثار اليات الاحتلال
التي داست هذه الجثث ما زالت ظهره يعطيك
العافيه ايش بتعمل بدور على جسس والله ل
سعيب
ام وبنتها الكبيره
والطفل وهنا بدور مش مقين شي حطنا لهم نص
ان شاء الله تسقار نقرهم الفاتحه اكثر من
هيك بنعملش وحسبي الله ونعم الوكيل عدد
الجثث كبير جدا الجثث التي نكلت في
واستخرجت من داخل القبور بفعل تجريف قوات
الاحتلال لهذه المنطقه للاسف كبيره وكثيره
جدا احنا هنا لقينا منباشر
منبين اليهود الاسرائيليين على القبور
وقاعدين بنحط الجسس تعنا بصفهم نعيد دفنهم
ثاني لقيناهم على الوجه
مرميين